>> Will Sentance: Cách khác mà tôi có thể làm, chức năng tích hợp của
JavaScript mà đầu ra sẽ là một đối tượng trống mãi mãi?
Vâng, Adam, làm ơn?
>> Adam: Object.create.
>> Will Sentance: Object.create, rất hay, từ Adam, vâng, ngay tại chỗ.
User3 bằng object.create.
Đây là một hàm tích hợp sẵn trong JavaScript.
Nó sẽ cung cấp cho chúng ta sau một số chi tiết, đó là một từ khó hiểu.
Cung cấp cho chúng tôi một số kiểm soát chi tiết đối với đối tượng của chúng tôi.
Nhưng tôi chỉ muốn tất cả các bạn biết bây giờ, đó là điều duy nhất
xét về bản thân đối tượng của chúng ta, mà nó thực hiện, là trả về một đối tượng rỗng.
Vì vậy, bên tay phải ở đây.
Chúng ta hãy khai báo phía bên trái ở đây trước.
Cho bạn Kayla.
Cố lên, tại sao tôi luôn bỏ qua lá thư cuối cùng?
Nó rất thú vị, phải không?
Chắc là tôi đang cố gắng đẩy nhanh quá trình viết của mình.
Được rồi.
Đầu tiên bên tay trái Kyla.
>> Kayla: Chúng tôi đang khai báo một Người dùng 3 không đổi.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, user3, xuất sắc.
Bên tay phải sẽ ngay lập tức trả lại cho chúng ta những gì Kyla?
>> Kayla: Một vật thể rỗng.
>> Will Sentance: Một đối tượng trống rỗng.
Đó là con người.
Và vì vậy, ngay cả khi tôi phải, >> Will Sentance: Even
nếu tôi đi vào các parethens đó,
bạn có thể nghĩ những người có kiến ​​thức là MD khôn ngoan.
Tôi có thể chuyển vào một đối tượng trong đó có đầy đủ các đối tượng đầy đủ các thuộc tính,
Tôi không quan trọng việc tôi vượt qua nó, tôi có thể vượt qua bất cứ thứ gì tôi muốn.
Nó sẽ trả về một đối tượng rỗng.
Bây giờ đối tượng trống đó có thể có một số thuộc tính ẩn tùy thuộc vào những gì chúng ta
chuyển vào, hoặc tài sản ẩn trên.
Nhưng nó luôn là một đối tượng rỗng, không có thuộc tính trực tiếp trên nó.
Sau đó, chúng tôi gán cho nó thuộc tính name, là giá trị.
Trường Eva mà đã lưu trữ trong đó.
9 và một lần nữa phương thức gia tăng là một hàm.
Hãy chỉ xác nhận xem tôi có thể làm điều quan trọng của riêng mình hay không.
Use3.increment, Todd tôi có thể giúp gì cho bạn không?
Lần đầu tiên của tôi lặp đi lặp lại và anh ấy là màu xanh lá cây của tôi khi tôi nhìn lên đây.
Có màu xanh lá cây cho cốc.
Tôi phải tìm user3 ở đâu, Todd?
>> Todd: Trong bộ nhớ Đối tượng.
>> Will Sentance: Evo memory, phải không?
>> Todd: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Tại sao tôi tìm kiếm số gia tăng?
>> Todd: Trong đối tượng user3.
>> Will Sentance: Và tôi có tìm thấy nó không.
>> Todd: Vâng. >> Will Sentance: Nếu tôi làm.
Lấy mã của nó và thực thi nó là một giấc mơ trở thành sự thật.
Đó là một giấc mơ trở thành sự thật.
Tôi đã làm điều này là một hướng đối tượng.
Tôi có dữ liệu và các hàm, các phương pháp dữ liệu hoạt động cùng nhau và
không làm việc với những thứ khác.
Bây giờ, tôi luôn có thể sử dụng chức năng này trong các lĩnh vực khác.
Vì vậy, nó không phải là loại được bảo vệ nghiêm ngặt nhưng để
mục đích chung, chúng tôi khá tốt để đi.
Nhưng tôi viết mã lặp đi lặp lại, Ryan đang phá vỡ những nguyên tắc nào?
>> Ryan: Vẽ. >> Di chúc: Vẽ,
Tôi không lặp lại chính bạn, chúng tôi tự tay tạo ra những đơn đặt hàng này.
Mỗi khi người dùng đăng nhập,
chúng tôi sẽ phải viết đầy đủ các nhà phát triển đằng sau hậu trường điền vào.
Thuộc tính của chúng.
Bất cứ khi nào chúng ta có mã đang được thực hiện nhiều lần, chẳng hạn như thêm thuộc tính.
Chúng ta có xu hướng làm gì bất cứ khi nào chúng ta thực hiện các dòng mã, lặp đi lặp lại?
Chúng ta gói chúng lại bằng gì, Todd?
>> Todd: Tôi sẽ khái quát hóa chức năng, trừu tượng hóa nó, xuống.
>> Will Sentance: Đặt trong một hàm.
Lưu nó một lần để sử dụng lại nhiều lần.
Và các bit duy nhất bạn muốn thay đổi có Parson làm đầu vào để chỉ định
khi bạn chạy hàm, nó thực sự sẽ làm gì.
Vâng, nhưng Todd chính xác là những gì chúng tôi sẽ làm.
Và mọi người giải pháp một cho và
Tôi chỉ muốn nói thêm một lần nữa trong trường hợp mọi người không thực sự cảm thấy điều này.
Đó là một giấc mơ trở thành hiện thực cho
tôi khi tôi đang viết với 100.000 dòng mã khi tôi nói dữ liệu của mình.
Không có gì bí ẩn về chức năng của tôi.
>> Will Sentance: Chà, chức năng của tôi là gì sẽ áp dụng cho điều đó
dữ liệu bởi vì nhìn vào dân gian đó, nó ở ngay đó.
Hàm có thể được áp dụng cho dữ liệu đó.
Và một khi bạn bắt đầu suy nghĩ về mô hình này,
đặt dữ liệu và chức năng của bạn cùng một nơi.
Tất cả các chức năng mà tôi có thể cần cho user3 đều có ở đó.
Một khi bạn bắt đầu suy nghĩ theo cách đó, bạn bắt đầu làm điều này rất nhiều.
Bạn bắt đầu nghĩ về mọi thứ trong ứng dụng của mình như
dữ liệu trong chức năng được kết nối với tính năng cụ thể đó là gì?
Nó thực sự rất, rất tuyệt.
Nó không phổ biến như lý do tại sao tôi thực sự nhấn mạnh
đây là về việc hiểu các nguyên tắc trong JavaScript.
Hãy để chúng tôi làm điều này, mà chúng tôi sử dụng khắp nơi.
Bởi vì mô hình của lập trình hướng đối tượng ngày càng không phổ biến
như phong cách lập trình chức năng, nhưng tuyệt vời, thực sự trực quan.
Cách nghĩ về cấu trúc một ứng dụng, ứng dụng là dữ liệu.
Điểm người dùng, bất kỳ chức năng nào, khả năng thay đổi điểm người dùng đó,
đặt nó lại với nhau.
Và nhìn vào nó, có phải ở đó không.
Đẹp, nhưng chúng tôi đang làm một thời gian di động.
Vì vậy, bây giờ chúng ta hãy thực hiện công việc tạo đối tượng, lưu nó một lần.
Tạo các đối tượng và sau đó sử dụng nó bao nhiêu lần tùy thích.
Đó chính xác là những gì chúng tôi sẽ làm ở đây.
Tạo các đối tượng của chúng tôi, tạo ra thậm chí không phải là từ phù hợp.
Tạo và trả về các đối tượng của chúng tôi bằng cách sử dụng một hàm.
Giải pháp này một người sẽ hóa ra là không thể thực hiện được.
Bạn không bao giờ có thể sử dụng nó trong thực tế, nhưng nó giúp chúng ta có một chặng đường dài.
Mọi thứ khác chúng tôi làm chỉ là làm cho điều này hiệu quả hơn nhiều.
Tôi đã cho bạn một gợi ý ở đó.